Da kann uns geoengineering retten vor dem klimawandel der existiert und immer weiter voranschreitet
Daran gibt es ja tragischerweise keinen zweifel inwieweit können wir ihnen mit herkömmlichen ideen wie etwa dem ausbau
erneuerbarer energien noch bei kommen gar nicht mehr dafür ist es viel zu spät das sagen einige experten
ihre ansätze sind krass und kurios zugleich denn sie wollen gezielt in das weltweite klimageschehen
eingreifen das stichwort geo engineering mit hightech gegen den klimawandel also ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
Gewünscht und ich beantworte die frage sind wir noch. Zu retten jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Sonnenschirme, im all oder künstliche vulkanausbrüche das sind nur zwei der vielen ansätze des forschungsbereiches namens geoengineering gemeint
Sind damit gezielte eingriffe der menschen in das klimageschehen wir haben hier schon ab und zu darüber berichtet das ziel die
strahlungsbilanz der erde zu beeinflussen oder die atmosphärische co2
konzentration, zu senken um den menschengemachten
klimawandel zu kompensieren oder zumindest abzuschwächen und die konkreten ansätze und projekte
Klingen nicht nur beim ersten eindruck kurios und kraß sondern sie haben es echt in sich dabei sind die diskussion um das geo-engineering
alles andere als neu vor allem in den 60er jahren wurden viele projekte ideen ins spiel gebracht beispielsweise
dachte man darüber nach zehn
Wasserstoffbomben unter dem eismeer zu zünden der dampf der explosionswolke würde in der oberen atmosphäre
gefrieren und so die
wärmestrahlung reduzieren der erhoffte effekt eine klimaverbesserung auf der gesamten erde durch veränderung der luftzirkulation
Doch wirklich zu ende gedacht sind solche ideen meist nicht meist nicht mehr als theoretische
Konstrukte sind sie und wie sollte es auch anders sein es gibt. Wohl kaum etwas
Komplexeres als das weltweite klimageschehen physik chemie und so weiter und so fort
Spielen da rein und so waren und sind die tatsächlichen auswirkungen der jeweiligen projekte meist absolut nicht vorhersehbar und genau hier
Setzt die kritik an werden bestehende risiken ignoriert
gefährden solche ideen das gesamte leben auf der erde und untergraben sie die herkömmlichen ansätze
treibhausgasemissionen zu reduzieren
bereits vor zehn jahren hatte der klimawissenschaftler alan robock eine liste zu den
Gefahren, des geo engineerings erstellt und seine dort aufgeführten risiken bezüglich umwelt
Um klimasystem sind auch heute noch mehr als aktuell
unvorstellbar seien die folgen die menschliches oder technisches versagen mit sich bringen würden zudem befürchtet robot dass durch solche projekte
Die bereitschaft sinkt co2 durch andere maßnahmen zu reduzieren zudem stellt er auf die frage nach einer übernationalen
Kontrolle denn wer sonst könne ausschließen dass die ideen für militärischen zwecken missbraucht würden doch wie soll sich solch ein weltweites
kontrollgremium finden lassen wenn doch einzelne staaten
interessenskonflikte haben die gegebenenfalls unvereinbar sind heißt
Im klartext welches land darf bestimmen wie warm es konkret werden soll wie viele es regnen soll und wieviel
Sonnenstunden es geben soll rohbock hat verschiedene szenarien, am computer durchgespielt und errechnet dass sich die globale durchschnittstemperatur
durch den einsatz von geoengineering tatsächlich senken lassen würde doch die nebeneffekte sind fatal
der sommer monsun in indien und china beispielsweise
Der überlebenswichtig für die bauern dort ist würde beeinträchtigt es würde wohl weniger regen dort fallen und auch andere geo engineering projekte
würden wohl fatale auswirkungen mit sich bringen dazu noch ein konkretes beispiel ein astronomie team der university of arizona
Beschäftigt sich mit dem themenbereich geo engineering und will den klimawandel auf der erde bekämpfen indem zwischen der sonne und der erde so etwas
aufgespannt wird wie ein gigantischer sonnenschirm konkret schlagen sie
siliziumscheiben vor die die einstrahlung der sonne um knapp zwei prozent reduzieren sollen 16 millionen dünne siliziumscheiben
müssten dafür mit hilfe elektromagnetischer
Kanonen ins all geschossen werden an dem punkt wo sich die anziehungskraft von erde und sonne
Aufheben würden sie sich dann auf rein und eine art sonnensegel bilden
Doch diese idee steckt noch in den kinderschuhen
Zum einen wäre dies natürlich mit gigantischen kosten verbunden zum anderen sind die risiken auch. Da kaum abzuwägen
modellrechnung sagen voraus dass sich die toten durch solch ein projekt abkühlen könnten
Arktis und antarktis könnten dagegen trotzdem wärmer werden und was würde solch ein projekt bahn bringt eine menge risiken aber nicht einmal 100
Erfolg und falls ihr jetzt denkt dass nur eine kleine zahl vielleicht etwas
Durchgedrehter wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler sich mit diesem thema dem thema
Des geo engineerings beschäftigt falsch gedacht selbst die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft dfg hat schon im mai
2013 ein entsprechendes projekt in angriff genommen doch auch hier mahnt man zur zurückhaltung in einer offiziellen stellungnahme
Heißt es dass die bisherige forschung, zu diesem thema stark auf die technischen möglichkeiten von climate engineering
ausgerichtet war die forschung sollte aber die wissenschaftlichen grundlagen
für eine bewertung von vor und nachteilen
unterschiedlicher maßnahmen des kleinen engineering schaffen dabei stellt das nur sehr beschränkte wissen über mögliche unerwünschte nebeneffekte
eine wichtige forschungslücke datum diese zu schließen müssten forschungsteams, aus verschiedenen bereichen einbezogen werden beispielsweise aus politik
wirtschaft recht und technik auch die position der deutschen bundesregierung zum geo engineering ist klar
man setze weiterhin auf klimaschutz und die minderung von treibhausgasemissionen sowie ihre anpassungsmaßnahmen
konkrete geo engineering projekte dagegen
verfolge man nicht viele andere regierungen dieser welt haben dagegen noch nicht ihre offizielle position zum thema öffentlich gemacht doch auch in china beispielsweise
forschen wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler mit staatlicher unterstützung
Dazu wie sich das klima das durch geo engineering verändert wurde auswirken würde konkret sind hier noch
keine versuche
Im freien geplant was das geo-engineering betrifft halten die meisten wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler und auch regierungschefs dieser erde
aber für deutlich zu früh solche techniken tatsächlich umzusetzen sie seien zu wenig erforscht und die auswirkungen
zu krass dennoch steht auch fest dass solche ideen nicht gleich von vornherein als mittel gegen die schlimmsten folgen der globalen erwärmung
Auszuschließen sind sagt zum beispiel auch david kies von der harvard university der seit 25 jahren zum themenfeld des geo
engineerings forscht er möchte
Schwefeldioxid im großen stil in die stratosphäre sprühen denn die partikel könnten das sonnenlicht reflektieren
so dass die temperatur auf der erde gesenkt würde diese methode das sogenannte solar radiation management ist also quasi an
künstlicher vulkan ausbruch 1991
Passierte dies auf natürliche art und weise als ein philippinischer vulkan 17 millionen tonnen schwefel partikel in die stratosphäre
schleuderte die durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde sank damals und knapp ein halbes grad der mit kies ist sich sicher
Die bisherigen forschungsergebnisse weisen darauf hin dass eine kleine menge
Wohldosiertes geoengineering weniger riskant ist als wenn wir es nicht machen die mehrheit der menschen auf der welt würde davon profitieren
aber natürlich müssen gleichzeitig die
treibhausgasemissionen reduziert werden komme was wolle seien die methode sei
kostengünstig einige milliarden dollar pro jahr werden angesetzt doch das eigentliche problem wird damit nicht behoben die treibhausgase in der atmosphäre
werden nicht weniger kritiker dieser idee befürchten dass durch diesen ansatz die ozonschicht
Beschädigt würde doch krieges lässt sich nicht abbringen noch in diesem jahr will er seine idee erstmals in der praxis
umsetzen mit hilfe eines ballons will er in 25 kilometern
Höhe artikel versprühen etwas schwefeldioxid und aluminium dann wieder zu meinen erforschen inwieweit diese tatsächlich die ozonschicht
angreifen zum anderen sollen sensoren messen wie stark die partikel die sonnenstrahlen reflektieren
Gefahren sieht in seinem vorhaben nicht die auswirkungen des experiments auf die stratosphäre seien vergleichbar mit dem einminütigen flug eines
passagierflugzeugs wenn er als erster neues zum thema geo engineering und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp dafür gibt's
hier den link
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg so mitmachen
und mehr themen vorschlagen oder an
Abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit
Genau der glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
Draufklicken geoengineering gegen klimawandel da geht es konkret. Um co2 recycling ansonsten bis dann
flattern